she had only been in the job 18 months
but you had a chorus of people calling
for her resignation that seemed to be
the one thing that everyone in
Washington could agree on she needed to
step down yeah bipartisan agreement on
that Trish in the official word coming
she submitted her resignation according
to a statement from the department of
homeland security to the DHS secretary
jeh Johnson earlier today he accepted
her resignation again 30 years of
service as you said she's been on the
job for 18 months and now Johnson says
that he is appointing as an acting head
of the Secret Service a former agent
Joseph Cheney and he retired in 2011
coming out of the private sector back to
the Secret Service to try and get them
through this current particular
challenge he's also to appointing the
deputy Homeland Security Secretary to
continue the review of what happened
when we had the fence jumping situation
at the White House so that's going to be
handled outside of the Secret Service by
the department of homeland security's
number two of officer and separately
Johnson announcing that an independent
panel is going to review security
protocols at the White House and review
the Secret Service in general that
independent panel will be named shortly
they're gonna have to report the
deadline here December 15th according to
jay johnson but trish one dad Lee we're
going to hear if not from the president
but from his press secretary Josh
earnest in just the next little bit as
to what the president thinks about all
this but it seemed like the writing was
on the wall yesterday after Julia
Pierson had a very tough time in front
of the house oversight committee wonder
peter and you wonder Sean how much is
simply a cultural problem within the
Secret Service I mean this is not just
her you think back to 2009 you had the
gatecrashers at the white house state
dinner 2012 12 you had agents leaving
after allegations of using prostitutes
in Columbia in just a few weeks ago we
learned that Secret Service permitted in
armed security guard with a criminal
record to get on an elevator in Atlanta
with the present and then of course the
fence jumper I mean how does this happen
Sean where's the accountability in all
this what kind of culture is it that
allows these things to keep transpiring
obviously these are very very sensitive
and serious issues when you see these
types of incidents
you've just described Trish I think it's
really important though while they need
to be looked at there needs to be an
independent review and I think that
that's appropriate let's not forget the
men and women of the Secret Service who
handle literally thousands of incidents
every single year successfully the
sacrifices that they're making willing
to put themselves on the line their
lives on the line missing time with
their families for months on end we've
got to remember how important they are
in the jobs they're doing successfully
let's look at the leadership let's look
at some of the protocols but let the
American public remember the the good
men and women and what they're doing
every single day to keep us safe Peter
Cook we know that the Obama family was
gone the day the fence jumper incident
happened might that have contributed it
all to people being a little bit more
relaxed shall we say when it came to
security threats well you've got to
imagine Trish that when the president
his family are not on the campus not on
the grounds that there is some
opportunity for the Secret Service
agents just naturally to let their guard
down a little bit but you know in this
instance they're not a lot of excuses to
justify what happened allowing the
person to enter the building and I think
that's probably one of the ramifications
in all this one of the consequences why
Julia Pierson is leaving